- So what was the Gilded
Age and why did it happen?
- Ah, the Gilded Age is
this fascinating period
from about 1870 to 1900,
you can change the dates
a little bit but that's,
so we're talking post Civil War,
America becomes an industrial
powerhouse, the cities rise.
So in 1850 fewer people live in the cities
than in the rural part of the country,
by 1900 more people live in the city.
And basically you have the
birth of the railroads,
the railroads get connected in 1869,
continental railroad going all
the way across the country.
You have the rise of
oil and John Rockefeller
and basically, this period,
think of Rockefeller and Vanderbilt, as,
and Carnegie and JP Morgan as powerful
the way we think of presidents.
Presidents during this period
kind of were on the descent
but the magnets of industry,
railroad, oil, steel,
those were all banking,
those were the superheroes in America,
and they led to this amazing
growth in industrialization
but then also huge disparities.
No labor laws that we would
be familiar with today.
So you had this
industrialization with people
working in the industries
who had no protections,
child labor, working 22 hours a day,
horrible health conditions.
So this gurgling, booming America,
but where there's great disparities
between who's doing well and who's not.
- And it was called Gilded
because those who were doing well
were living very well.
- Right, Gilded as in a gilded
frame, covered with cold
which came from a novel by Mark Twain.
And that's right, it takes on
the caste of this extraordinary wealth.
Rockefeller was the first
billionaire in America,
Vanderbilt built the biggest house,
still the biggest house in
America during this period.
So the wealth was, people would
make eight to $10 in a week,
some of these tycoons were
making eight to $10 in a minute.
And so that kind of vast wealth,
because you could only
make so much wealth before,
this is just mountains of wealth
and then also, again,
this great disparity.
- And it seems like it came
from, really, technology.
Technology allowed all
of this productivity,
the railroads, steel,
et cetera, et cetera,
and then of course finance
was able to get in there
and help move capital more efficiently.
What parallels do you
see with our current age
where technology seems to
be doing something similar
where we have all of these new
industries, and new wealth,
but some fear that it might
be causing some inequality.
- You have, yes, you
have a couple of things.
You have innovation in these
very different industries,
both innovation in the creation of things
but then also innovations in
the structures of business.
Buying up small business,
creating big conglomerates.
Then using that leverage and power
to then crowd out competitors for sure
but then also raise prices
because you're the only game in town.
And you also have business
practices that are not
the sort of laissez-faire
economic belief said essentially
that in the economy it was
like in the American system,
which was let it operate.
Don't get in the way, don't mess with it,
because when it operates
it runs the most efficiently for America.
- In the end markets can be messy
but they're gonna have the best outcome.
- That's right.
- Is the argument behind laissez-faire.
- That's exactly right, and
it got this wonderful assist
from Charles Darwin who said,
we can explain the growth of,
or you can explain the species
and we can explain our natural world
with this theory about the
competition among the species
and this term survival of the
fittest, social Darwinism,
survival of the fittest, which some,
and I certainly thought might've
come from Darwin didn't,
it came from Herbert Spencer
who basically had an economic theory
of the survival of the fittest
and then it went this way.
Some people have more talent than others
and when they exercise their
talent they do very well
and that's the best thing for society.
It believed that society
was ever increasing,
it didn't mean that every
single person was increasing,
but that if you followed
survival of the fittest
and the best people did the best
then ultimately society will always be
on an evolutionary plane of moving upward.
And so that was the theory behind
get out of the way of these
big companies and big tycoons
and they will do the best for America
and so the reason that was important
was A, it kept government out of the way,
B, it kept religious,
it created a religion,
it was a secular religion of course,
but it created a theory that said,
wow that looks like what you're doing
is totally self interested but
there's this theory behind it
and everybody will
improve so okay, go ahead.
- Yeah, that was the beginning
of Gordon Gekko's famous greed is good.
- Right, right, yeah.
Yeah, greed is good, so the
comparison to our current moment
is you have huge disparity
and technologies that are,
to use a cliche of the day, disruptive
that are completely changing
the way everybody does business,
changing when we think about the way
in which Americans behave,
that rapid sense of change,
it's changing culture rapidly
and it's making big winners and losers
and those big disparities exist as well.
- How did the Gilded Age play out?
Were some of these forces
moderated eventually,
maybe around 1900,
and do you think similar
things might happen for us?
- There were two big moderation
in response to the Gilded Age.
You had government came awake again
and then you also had labor movements
that came into formation,
basically to slow down the growth
and the rapacious demands
of the Gilded Age.
Politics during the
Gilded Age kind of went,
became an offshoot of
the titans of industry.
If you look at the presidency
between 1876 and 1892
they're all one term presidents
and none of them get
more than 50% of the vote
and basically what the
presidents spend their time doing
is using the spoil system,
which is essentially
putting people in jobs
to pay off the local bosses
who helped them get elected.
So getting elected became
a job of staying elected
and that meant dolling out patronage,
basically giving people
jobs who were your friends
so that they would go and vote for you
because these elections
were all very close
and that's not getting a lot
of work done for the people.
Some of 'em, Rutherford B. Hayes
tried these little efforts
at civil service reform,
which essentially meant
putting people in jobs
who could monitor the factories,
make sure that people
weren't getting abused
or that health wasn't declining
or that anything that
a government might do
that we think of today
but his political
patrons didn't want that.
So that was all very hard to do.
What happened on the worker's
end is they realized,
and the most famous moment was in 1911,
the Triangle Shirtwaist Fire where
a number of women working
in a garment factory are,
there's a fire and the
bosses lock the doors
and I think 40 some odd
women die, mostly women,
and it highlighted the labor issues
but labor unions start to organize
and there are huge clashes and
strikes and consumer boycotts
and those start to put
some pressure on business
to change their practices, at
least in terms of worker hours
and the kinds of things that we now
would certainly take for granted.
- Fascinating.
- It's an incredible period.
- Yeah.